there's part of me that thinks ice
lenders might not be the brightest of
people I mean look at this place
it's mostly made up of barren volcanic
rock the belches
pushing the foul smell of sulfur
throughout the countryside animals and
plants have avoided this cold hard land
and so too should have humans but as we
all know humans are a stupid yet
wonderfully determined species we often
live where we're not welcome over the
last hundred years I cylinders found a
way not just to survive but to thrive
they became some of the world's best
fishermen they invented their ways out
of problems and they even found a way to
turn their love of sagas elvish folklore
and storytelling into massive businesses
this is a place where the land and a
never-ending battle with nature has had
a profound influence on the country's
technology travel with me as we head
from Reykjavik to the Icelandic Coast
slice some fish with algorithms and warp
into an entirely different universe to
explore Eve one of the most amazing
video games ever created all on this
episode of hello world
Silicon Valley may be home to some of
the biggest tech giants in the world but
it's being challenged like never before
crazy tech geniuses have popped up all
over the planet making things that will
blow your mind my name is Ashley Vance
I'm an author and journalist and I'm on
a quest to find the most innovative tech
creations and meet the beautiful freaks
behind them hello world
a hundred years ago Iceland lumbered
along is one of the poorest countries in
Europe
then during the Second World War it's
fishermen took great risks sailing
through minefields dodging warships and
submarines to feed the continent
rich is poured in in the country
industrialized and modernized within a
couple of decades I've traveled to the
fishing village of grynn Davich on the
country's southwest shore to see just
how far Iceland's fishing industry has
come boats arrive here every morning
packed full of cod and redfish and then
get transported to nearby processing
plates
inside one of these plants sits the most
advanced fish slicing gear on the planet
it's a machine made by the Icelandic
tech giant morale and it uses algorithms
to carve up the fillets then end up on
your plate we're gonna head into the
factory floor where they've got a couple
of the new morale machines it's people
and machines working side by side and
I'm sure it's gonna smell pretty foul I
prepped for the mechanized river of
death with good Borg
she's a mechanical engineer turned
operations guru who has spent the last
few months overseeing the installation
of these machines this is the Machine
Ferrari a fish slicer meet the Flexi cut
first it x-rays the fish to spot bones
and then a water jet slices the fish
with great precision dozens of programs
run on the machine to slice the fish
just as customers want
if Tony Stark wanted to make fish tanks
this would be his machine what's the key
technology behind that machine to be
able to see the fillet and craft it each
time and every time the same when you're
doing the x-ray what is the software
doing yeah calculating exactly how to
cut because you are towing fish on the
water jet so you need to be very
accurate and at 50 fish per minute how
quickly is it making that decision we
have less than a second to work take a
picture estimate and cut there's
everybody worried that the machines are
gonna come take their jobs yeah that
this are usually a warrior when you have
technology replacing manual work we say
we are actually creating technological
Joplin's that
the reality is the humans will find it
tough to compete with these kinds of
machines perhaps with a bit of luck a
human touch will be required for the
fishy leftovers the morale hopes to
process next there's a lot to gain still
I think we haven't even started to
explore the value of byproducts of the
seafood
ice lenders as if a wholesome fish diet
wasn't enough they go about their daily
lives secure in the knowledge that 100%
of their country's energy is renewable
partly thanks to this stuff Iceland has
turned its volcanoes into allies
tapping geothermal pockets to eat homes
and water using hydroelectric dams for
electricity this energy self-sufficiency
is key to Iceland's prosperity now
Iceland hopes to export its green energy
smarts some clever engineers have
created a funky rugged wind turbine
it'll be used in Iceland to power
isolated summer homes and remote
industrial equipment and to bring green
energy to rural areas overseas run
outside of the highway about 20 miles
outside of Reykjavik you can see this
little guy spinning around all day
powering telecommunications equipment
back in downtown reykjavik there's
smaller versions of this sitting on top
of a bus stop they're powering a Wi-Fi
base station and advertising board and a
smartphone recharging station
in an industrial suburb on the edge of
reykjavik the company called Icewind has
set up shop in an abandoned coal power
plant to build these turbines by hand
it's run by thor the company's business
chief and see thor a former nuclear
engineer this type of turbine is called
the sovereign use vertical axis wind
turbine in case you missed it that would
be a savonius vertical access wind
turbine for all you turbine noobs out
there technically it's an old technology
I mean it dates back to the Persian
Empire or something we have taken this
base design and kind of brought it to
the modern age with modern materials
carbon fiber or stainless steel we've
made it really really strong we have
engineered and cut the blades so that
the turbine never goes on over spin and
we just done the system so it's really
really simple and therefore we can keep
the price down but it also can take
really really harsh weather
and weather is a serious problem this is
what can happen to a conventional wind
turbine when excessive wind speeds hit
in Iceland windmills can last for about
three years before the weather does the
min
the shape of the ice wind turbines
allows them to function in low wind and
to stop from spinning out of control and
high wind and beyond that they just look
cool people when they look at it they
don't realize what it is they just think
it's a sculpture or something they're
not thinking about this as an ugly
energy production twice so mister is
putting more emphasis on the design
itself how it looks all the curves and
stuff like that I swing has trials
running throughout this country and
expects to begin selling its turbines
worldwide later this year Thor is
anxious to test out Iceland's ingenuity
on a bigger stage
we've been isolated for a long time and
I think we're fought for a long time for
several different things this is just
part of the fighting inventing new
things and going you lazy
but at least for now Iceland still
depends heavily on geothermal power
sorry Thor's these types of power plants
are so prevalent that Iceland turned one
of them into its biggest tourist
attraction an hour's drive south of
Reykjavik brings you to the Blue Lagoon
a man-made giant hot tub smack in the
middle of a lava field fed by mineral
rich wastewater that starts 2,000 metres
below the earth's surface and then gets
processed by a nearby power station and
fed into the lagoon feels like you're
swimming in the middle of volcano it's a
surreal experience like taking a bath on
another planet gets a float in this warm
water even when it's freezing cold
outside there's a swim up bar where you
can get a beer
and if you want that all-natural power
plant glow you can pay an exorbitant fee
for some silica silica mask and cold
beer giant hot tub it's perfect the last
part of the ritual is getting out of the
cold getting into a nice clean rub but
we're gonna have to do this again cuz I
can't find the armhole heat exhaustion
kicking in I called it a day leaving
others to soak up this places geothermal
goodness next up I ditched my intercom
for a straight shot of adrenaline Oh
courtesy of some Icelandic adventurers
with tech infused trucks like truck
ballet
you remember that volcano that erupted
in 2010 the one with the name no one
could pronounce well it was a blessing
in disguise for the country that
eruption gave Iceland some serious brand
recognition with tourists Iceland's
tourism industry is growing 30% per year
with 1.5 million people visiting in 2015
this boom of tourists has helped the
country climb out of the economic ruin
caused by the 2008 financial crisis the
thing is tourists suck but there's an
easy way to avoid them just hitch a ride
with these guys this is Arctic trucks a
one-of-a-kind body shop based in rake of
it that converts trucks into super
trucks that can take on just about
anything I want to show you this room
with the tires this operation is the
brainchild of Emil grim Seth so this
will have 46 inch tires is quite big 46
inch tires okay so you have to extend
the body it's a foot a foot and a half
app Emil and his crew ripped the trucks
apart stretch them hardened the
underbody and axles then they put on
these massive tires which can be
deflated quickly for better traction on
the snow if you want to hunt some elves
or see all of the natural splendors that
Iceland has to offer
Emile and his crew will work up a trip
and take you on one hell of an adventure
oh yeah
I'm a Texan slash California and who's
not done much snow driving Jeff any tips
for me before we go ah yeah you're
staying on the snow okay we're done
miles miles miles miles miles laughs
yeah
like Chuck ballet this must be it it's
like on Mars or something I mean without
the snow I guess joyriding up at the
brown
I've got a little boy the hang-up about
after shredding the snow and smiling
until my face cramped we emerged at the
edge of a volcano the snow and sky
seemed to merge into one producing a
view unlike anything else I've ever seen
and what do you do when you find
yourself at the spot that separates
heaven from earth you throw some burgers
on the grill say this about Vikings they
tailgate like pros who knew after
spending 15 hours with the lads it was
time to push on and keep getting weird
the truth of the matter is that unlike
most people I didn't visit Iceland to
take in the countryside or find the
first puffin of the season all of that
stuff was the garnish on my trip no I
came here for urban chaos drunken joy
and an explosion of raw emotion I came
here for the cultural phenomenon known
as Eve FanFest
buckle up because things are about to
get weird
nerds thousands of them make an annual
pilgrimage to Reykjavik to celebrate EVE
Online a massive multiplayer online game
that takes place in outer space for
three days the gamers come together
dress up like their favorite characters
shop from an endless supply of swag
we should buy one of these and get a
sneak peek what's on the horizon there's
also a massive live tournament to decide
who will become one of the main rulers
of the EVE universe where we shall
coronate our new leader and the losers
shall ritually sacrifice themselves it's
not going to last for much longer head
trading blow for blow here in the final
last night
can goes down
walk the halls here and you'll quickly
find yourself face to face with a wide
variety of geek species how many hours
would you play a day I'm logged into Eve
probably six hours a day seven days a
week if I don't have other plans we're
logging in at least two or three times a
week and joining police and telling
people it never stops and if you miss a
day then you're gonna have to make it up
the next day some people are the nicest
people you've ever met a rootless like
thugs and bandits
at its most basic level EVE Online is a
war game set in space people build their
characters from scratch
hop in ships like this band together by
the thousands to form armies and fight
battles that can take months even years
you've got its start back in 2003 and
today it's evolved into a vast universe
nearly as rich and complex as the real
world with a completely developed
political system and social hierarchy
there's a complex economy too based on
billions of transactions and lots of
manual labor all the ships all the
ammunition all the parts of all the
pieces that go on your ship the drones
the guns all of that was built by
someone and since there's a lot of
things in EVE it's huge
before players can zoom off to battle
they must spend weeks mining materials
to build ships and weapons this Titan is
one of the largest class ships it can
take six weeks to make and is over 8.5
miles long coalition's spend years
obtaining their space gear and they can
lose it all with one bad decision what's
the lowest feeling you've ever had
lowest feeling I've ever had was losing
my own type
there's nothing like losing about six
thousand real-world dollars in virtual
equipment you know in in you know in the
blink of an eye most games of this type
split people up into groups of a couple
thousand players and give everyone
missions to accomplish not Eve from the
outset it's been a game where all of the
players inhabit a single universe and
they collectively decide how the game
should be played
this makes Eve a neverending story
a spectacular communal experience so all
four hundred thousand some odd people
who play this game we are playing
together you get to know the same people
and there we have space celebrities we
have space politicians if people know
who they are if you're a hero or villain
and Eve half a million people know your
name know your reputation and will
either try to take you down or follow
you you know as a result of that what's
your status
lots of games offer people an escape but
none more so than you the Placid become
great warriors the shy turn into
socialites Eve is about becoming
something bigger or at least different
than what you are in real life there
will
be consequences hi alright okay my name
is Charles white I play Mac singularity
on EVE Online and the creature I am
wearing is an in-game item okay and it's
called a FET oh okay what's your role in
the game
well because I'm an older guy I just
started game giving advice on on the
comms and the players promoted me to the
position of hope of EVE Online so I
became the space Pope I give blessings
I've done two weddings real world
wedding I've blessed like six babies
already our chain of command often goes
the way that I believe most do you have
Wolfpack 10 works as a mechanic by day
when he logs on he becomes a fleet
commander with hundreds of obedient
soldiers ready to follow his orders I've
personally led little over 700 some
people who let thousands do you feel
like you have two lives I don't feel
like I had two lives I feel like I have
one life that is very complicated I try
not to separate what I do and Eve from a
reality because it has an impact and at
the same time I try not to let Eve
become so real that I give up things and
you know my regular day job and my life
and seeing my real world friends for
again it's easy to write off Eve players
as obsessive online gaming nerds really
easy but that would do a disservice to
the depth of the game and the fan fest
experience the bonds that are made and
generated they become members of the
kind of like an extended family I've
been here four times and we see the same
guys here like it's your buddy now
because you've been flying with him for
years and coming here honestly any time
that I get to go out and just hang out
with my nerd brethren it's it's been
pretty fun do you think you'll play for
the rest of your life probably I don't
ever imagine not naive so there's enough
of this game to keep you interested
there so many things I don't know at
this point if you ask me about wormhole
space I have no idea how it works I know
they exist I know I can go through
wormholes but I never lived in there
I've never even seen what you can do in
there there's so much to eve such a big
world bit harder when you're done
spending a day hanging out with your
fellow space warlords there's only one
thing left to do
pub crawl this is a tradition at fan
fest starts at 9 o'clock ends at 5 see
if I make it watching these gamers party
with each other something I'll never
forget
but there's something so human and
endearing about seeing people in their
element feeling free to express
themselves
it's hard not to join in coming up I'll
meet the people who concocted this
amazing universe in a strange twist
ablaze the utopian perfectly and find
out what they plan to do with humans
next
respect the hell out of this game
having met some of the Eve players you
may have noticed a trend the game tends
to attract smart passionate often
devious people managing these people is
hard sort of like herding deranged cats
that have been doing lots of drugs for
13 years this management burden has been
the job of CCP games the Icelandic game
studio that invented Eve since Eve has
few rules CCP has had to work hand in
hand with the players to shape the game
and introduce new stuff to buy in new
places to go some of the key input from
both sides arrives at fan fest we're
important things like wormhole Terrans
would get debate are you concerned about
how hard it is for us to worm roll
wormholes at this point do you feel like
it's about the right balance the depth
of this two-way relationship is unique
in the gaming industry
welcome to e5 phase 2016 one of the key
people who shape the vision of Eve the
ccp's longtime CEO Hilmar patterson
Nomar is something of a philosopher when
it comes to Iceland science fiction and
the role that Eve may play in nothing
less than the evolution of the human
species why does it make so much sense
that this game started in Iceland when
you're a kid in Iceland you develop a
clear sense that the country is here to
kill you
and if you don't pay attention you're
just gonna die
we have volcanoes and blizzards and
avalanches and God knows what you really
have to band together against the
elements
you started out from humble beginnings
three young computer savvy ice lenders
raised the money to build Eve by selling
a board game called header schpeel or
the danger game in English which ended
up being a smash hit funds in hand they
left from the dining room table to the
Stars building a beautiful and iconic
interpretation of life in space as
Hilmar sees it Eve might now provide a
roadmap for an interstellar society we
very much think about the game as a
construct to inspire the manifest
destiny of mankind which is to grow
beyond this planet so we cannot look at
Eve online the closest thing you have
today to live in space so and we believe
by giving hundreds of thousands and
millions of people that experience and
that dream we will bring closer to us
the desire and drive to make it actually
concretely happen
CCP has just released a new game called
Valkyrie it's a pure blow em up high
action space war game built for the
virtual reality headsets just coming to
market investors have recently poured
money into CCP betting that it will
figure out how to merge the best parts
of Eve and Valkyrie and create the first
meaningful virtual social network where
do you see all this technology heading
what we wanted to do with Valkyrie was
to do something very more immersive
something like immediately impactful on
your kind of emotional state take down
that Charlotte shop all right Eve does
that differently because it's more
slow-paced and methodical there's more
to your brain than to your heart and
ultimately the dream is to can immerse
these two concepts
Gilmartin in vetti's but this guy did
he's Rainier Hardison one of the three
co-creators of the game he explained the
origins of Eve to me near a monument
located beside the Reykjavik marina it
was built to honor the Eve players with
their gamer handles each tin to the base
all during fan fest people come to find
their names and pay homage to the game
people feel very passionate about this
and the strange thing about it when you
when you log into it it doesn't feel
like you're playing again it feels like
you're logging into a real world and
these people feel it too big and the
reason is because it's it's really about
human you know it's about humans
interacting it's about human emotion and
you know whatever makes it human why do
you think we will get all that at their
jobs and then come and work another job
and seek to feel that at home after I
would say it's kind of a you know it's
in a strange twisted way it's a it's an
utopian perfectly but it's riddled with
warrants drivin and everything but
everyone can you know aspire to be
something big
at the very end of fan fest the eve
players and CCP employees celebrate with
a raucous party at the Harper concert
hall it's one final booze and heavy
metal infused time together
before they go home and return to the
doldrums of regular life
there's a lyrical quality to so much
about this place to the way people weave
stories into their daily lives to the
way in which they seem to celebrate
suffering and to the way in which they
approach technology and fold it into
their culture this country is a
testament to the triumph of the human
will and to the power of imagination
it's the kind of place where the
surroundings beg you to get lost in your
thoughts and then smile deep down in
your soul up next on hello world I'm off
to another alien landscape the Mojave
Desert where a freedom seeking breed of
wild inventors have created a playground
to push just about every type of vehicle
from cars to spaceships to their lives